Alright guys, so in this lecture, I'm gonna show you
how I personally use ABCD tweeting strategy
and trust me guys, this is like, I would say,
even powerful than ABC, if used properly.
And I'm gonna show you how to use it properly.
So how do I use ABCD tweeting strategy?
First of all, as I said before,
I look at the overall market structure.
Are we bullish or are we bearish?
Okay, once I know the direction of the market,
so I look back 30 days or 20 days,
and if the market is going up, I look for longs.
And if the market has been going down
for the past 30 days, I only shot guys.
That is one simple rule, to identify trends.
So, you have A, B, C, right?
You look for D-leg, okay?
And after that, you look for market structure shift
on a smaller timeframe, okay?
So there could be structure here.
Now, unlike, so in ABCD strategy,
we look for market structure shift above the range
or below the range, okay?
But in ABCD, what can happen is,
as long as this level is not broken,
you can look for market structure shifts.
And while this level gets broken,
you can still look for market structure shifts, okay?
If the trend is bullish, right?
This level can act as a liquidity level as well.
But most of the time, the pattern is gonna look like this.
A, B, C, D.
The D-leg takes out the low of the B-leg,
and then you look at the market structure shift
on a smaller timeframe.
So, the recommended timing,
the timing that I use,
the timeframe that I use for this strategy is four hour
and 15 minutes, okay?
And guys, trust me, I'm not lying.
This is like the best timeframe to use these strategies.
So, on the four hour, you look at the market structure
and you identify the ABC pattern.
And after that, you look for the D-leg
that takes out the low of the B-leg.
Once that low is taken out,
you drop down to 15 minutes timeframe,
and then you look for market structure shift,
with displacement that has favorably gapped
before market structure shift.
And you take your entry during Killzone hours, okay?
As explained in the ABC video, I have shown the timings.
You must follow that timing.
And you take your entry and you can look for one to two,
target some favorably gapped here.
Probably there is a supply zone or an auto block
with favorably gapped.
Your first target would be that.
You would take some partials,
you take some partials along the way,
and probably you could be trading your stop loss.
It really depends on your risk management style.
So, similarly, if we have a downtrend
for the past 30 days or 20 days,
you look for a purge of this level.
So we have ABC and this D-leg
takes out the high of the B-leg right here.
Once that is taken out,
you look for market structure shift on 15 minute timeframe.
And yeah, it's gonna break out perfectly, okay?
Now, sometimes what I do to make it even more perfect,
I would look for an ABC panel like that.
And I would use the fib from the start of a leg
and the end of C-leg.
And if the D-leg comes into 0.705 level of fib
or 0.79 level, right?
And then gives you a market structure shift.
Then guys, that is an A-plus setup, I would say, okay?
I mean, the previous setup is also A-plus,
but this adds in more confluence, right?
And if there is a perfect auto block
with fair value gap around this level,
then oh guys, trust me, you're gonna love
when this trade's gonna play out in your favor.
So you look for market structure shift on 15 minutes,
when price touches the 0.705 or 0.79 level
or an auto block around this area, right?
And I could say 0.5 above the 0.5 level
if you find an auto block or these levels,
the ODE levels, 0.79, 0.705.
You look for market structure shift
and you take your entry targeting favor gaps or auto blocks.
So let me give you guys a couple of examples.